تشارك عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه اليوم في مظاهره
كبرى قباله وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه في
تل ابيب تبدا مساء اليوم وتستمر
24 ساعه مع دخول الحرب يومها المئه واقامت
هيئه عائلات المحتجزين في قطاع غزه مجسما
كبيرا لنفق مشابه للانفاق في قطاع غزه في
ميدان المحتجزين والمفقودين قباله وزاره
الدفاع في تل ابيب تهدف هذه الخطوه الى
ابراز معاناه الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه وتعريف المتضامنين
مع العائلات بما يواجهونه من صعاب وظروف
قاسيه داخل الانفاق في
غزه وما نشاهده الان صور مباشره لهذه
التظاهر من قلب تل
ابيب معنا الان من تل ابيب مراسلتنا فاطمه
خم مايسي ربما هذه المظاهره رتب له من قبل
ان يظهر هذا الخبر الذي اوردناه في بدايه
هذه الساعه الاخباريه عن اعلان كتاب
القسام فقدانها الاتصال بخليه كانت تحتجز
رهائن من
24 لا ادري اذا كان هذا الخبر قد وصل
لهؤلاء المتظاهرين ولكن في النهايه هو في
صلب ما يعترضون عليه حدثينا عن الاصداء
وما يمكن ان نتوقعه الليله في هذه
المظاهره التي تستمر 24
ساعه بقول صحيح ليلى يعني كما تشاهدين من
خلفي مئات الاسرائيليين بداوا بالتجمع هنا
في هذه المنطقه الحيويه التي تقع قباله
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه واذا ما اردنا
ان نرصد المشهد عبر عدسه زميلي اثار ابو
غربيه نستطيع ان نرى توافد مئات
الاسرائيليين الى هذه المنطقه لتشكيل ضغط
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه وعلى صناع القرار
في اسرائيل لاستئناف المفاوضات من اجل
التوصل الى اتفاقيه لتبادل الاسرى واطلاق
صراح الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
غزه طبعا هذه المظاهره تاتي ضمن عدد اخر
من المظاهرات المتفرقه التي تنتشر في
انحاء اسرائيل نتحدث شمالا في مدينه حيفا
جنوبا في بئر السبع وايضا في مناطق متفرقه
ولكن اهميه هذه المظاهرات انها تقع في تل
ابيب وايضا تاتي قبل ساعات قليله من مؤتمر
صحفي مرتقب لرئيس الحكومه الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو وكما ذكرت هنالك تطورات
جدا مهمه في غزه وعلى ما يبدو ان هنالك
يعني فقدان الاتصال بعدد من الاسرى
الاسرائيليين بلا شك ينعكس هنا على الشارع
الاسرائيلي طبعا هذا الامر من المتوقع ان
يقوم ويلاقي اصداء جدا كبيره ونتحدث عن
مواصله الضغط والحراك الاسرائيلي بخصوص
موضوع ومساله الا افراج عن الاسرى
الاسرائيليين خاصه ان عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين تقول بان ملف اعاده ابنائهم
الى بيوتهم ليس بضمن اولويه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ايضا مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
سيجتمع هذه الليله ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم الاعلان عن الموضوع الذي سيتم مناقشته
ولكن هذه المظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي سوف
تستمر طيله الساعه الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
ترافق ايضا مع دعوات للاضراب بشكل كامل
نتحدث عن دعوات للاضراب في كامل مناحي
الحياه وهذا الامر سيترتب عليه شل
للاقتصاد الاسرائيلي مده 100 دقيقه على
الاقل نتحدث عن مواصله الضغط العائلات
عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين يصعدون من
الاحتجاج خاصه واننا نتحدث عن مرور 100
يوم على هذه الحرب حرب اسرائيل على غزه
وبالتالي هذا بلا شك ينعكس على الشارع
الاسرائيلي وعلى هذه الاحتجاجات ومن
المتوقع ان تستمر هذه الاحتجاجات والوقفات
الاحتجاجيه كوسيله للضغط على حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو هنالك تحميل مسؤوليه لهذه
الحكومه حتى ان بعض المظاهرات تطالب
باقاله حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو واقاله هذه
الحكومه وتفكيكها والذهاب الى انتخابات
المبكره بعض الوقفات الاحتجاجيه ايضا
تطالب بوقف كامل لاط النار والذهاب الى
هدنه وابرام
صفقه واتفاقيه تقضي في نهايه المطاف
لاطلاق صراح الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه 100
يوم تشارف على الاقتراب على هذه الحرب
وبالتالي هذا الامر ينعكس هنا على مستوى
الشارع الضغط والاحتجاجات تستمر بالتصاعد
خاصه وان العائلات تصرح بانها ستقوم
بالتصعيد وان هذا الامر سيترافع خسائر
اقتصاديه جدا كبيره نتحدث عنم يوم غد
سيكون في ساعات الصباح وسوف يستمر 100
دقيقه وبالتالي سوف ننتظر المؤتمر الصحفي
لرئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو وهل هذا
الامر سيتناول مساله المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين لان على مستوى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هذه هذا الملف يقع من ضمن
الامور والاهداف التي وضعتها الحكومه في
هذه الحرب ولكن هنا على ما يبدو لا يوجد
ثقه
بحكومه جمعات الا نتظر ونرى اذا كان فعلا
سيتطرق الى هذه النقطه اشكرك جزيلا فاطمه
خميسي من تلبي